jimmy great to see you how you doing i
am doing well this uh kind of crazy
right like what what the heck happened
here like 20 000 people or something
yeah yeah there's a lot of people here
today so i'd love to get your opinion of
course on bitcoin at a bitcoin
conference i want to know what do you
see the future of bitcoin in terms of
payments is it going to be that medium
of exchange or is it going to replace
gold as that store of value i think both
um you're seeing that in el salvador
definitely where it's a method of
payment because it's a cash economy and
the ability to do digital payments is a
huge step up for a lot of people um
you're seeing the effects that it's
having with like the mortgages and stuff
like that um you know a
news story is doing some amazing stuff
there uh in alexander i i think it will
be there for especially in the
developing world as a method of payment
um i i think more in the first world
you're going to see it as a method of
savings because
inflation is hitting everybody the
unconfiscated ability is actually a very
critical feature as we saw with the
canadian truckers
yeah that non-confiscatable part is what
governments absolutely hate
so how do you see us moving forward
there's a lot of hostility from the sec
from the senate um elizabeth warren
refuses to understand um that it's not
necessarily moralist activity so how do
you see us sort of fighting that battle
yeah that's a great question i suspect
that we're gonna need to actually go and
lobby which is why i'm part of the
bitcoin today coalition and i wrote a
book uh bitcoin and the american dream
for that reason uh with uh with a bunch
of other people we're trying to teach
policymakers what bitcoin is and help
them understand it's not just a bunch of
anarcho-capitalists libertarian finance
bros that are in their 20s it's actually
people like you people you know the
black bitcoin billionaires military
veterans it's like boomers and all these
other people that you wouldn't
necessarily expect to be bitcoiners but
they actually are and
learning that and understanding what
bitcoin actually means for all of these
people that that's going to be critical
for them to understand and support
bitcoin the way it should be and just
one final question where do you think
we're at with mass adoption right now um
i would say like in terms of internet if
you think um like 94 was when it started
getting popular i'd say we're in like
the 97 98 though yeah totally agree
thank you so